to break the land speed record your car
needs to be special to break the 1000
mile an hour mark it needs to be an apex
of technology this is the newly unveiled
cockpit of the Bloodhound a jet on
wheels to you and me the comfort of the
pilot and here's a fighter pilot his
cabin has to suit him
the steering wheel is 3d printed
titanium shapes to pilot Andy Greene's
hands but that's not all that's bespoke
he sat in a pool of resin to produce the
shape of his seat during a 1,000 mile an
hour run bloodhound will cover 12 miles
in two minutes for the drivers safety
everything has to be perfect so you
might think aircon is an unnecessary
extra it's not for the pilot it's to
keep the electronics cool those
instruments have been coated with a
special non reflective paint for optimum
visibility the walls are white for
maximum brightness the windscreen is
thicker than a fighter jets you can
survive an impact of a 1 kilogram bird
at 900 miles an hour
onboard one jet engine and two rockets
they provide 21 tons of thrust that's
the same as 180 Formula one cars 5 years
of design and build so far the
Bloodhound team are aiming for a 2016
launch